[Music]
check this out
fourth of july is coming and remember we
showed the meme well nbc had no choice
but to report on it let's dig in a
little bit more now and talk about just
how expensive this 4th of july is going
to be for everyone take that backyard
barbecue the average price tag for a
cookout for 10 is nearly 70
that's up 10 bucks from just last year
kristen myers is editor-in-chief of the
balance and joins us now so chris let's
see if she tells us
when hot dogs are 19 cents cheaper
that's why i got in heavy last four
years well those aren't like obama's hot
dogs
there he is
alex what's going on
how you doing no no you guys they told
me like 45 minutes ago you guys were
having the technical stuff where we were
so i literally i get sleepy this time of
day siesta they were like banging on my
door like 10 minutes ago wake up they're
ready
so i literally took a 10-minute nap yeah
and uh i'm here and i i love the show
and there's so much to talk about but
obviously you guys are being sarcastic
there's not unlimited us dollars to
print the world's moving away from the
us dollar and we're seeing the inflation
caused by that over printing so the
chickens have come home to roost and
welcome the new world order i know you
guys were talking about it earlier but
what do you make of the white house
spokesperson saying well you got to pay
more for gas as a transition to the
liberal new world order
well here's what i think and this this
you know
they love this right i i they're
pretending like oh no people are
suffering we're going to do everything
we can they've wanted this forever this
is christmas for them this means that
people are going to go now they want
people to have a conversation going like
look honey should we buy a home or she
keep should we keep running and buy an
electric car because that's how much
they are this is what they want man this
is what they want they want us dependent
on on everybody else i don't know if you
saw earlier but uganda just found 12
trillion dollars in gold right in mining
12 trillion dollars and i go you mean
china just found 12 trillion dollars in
gold because they own africa
that's exactly what's happened the
globalists have positioned china to take
over
they've made it impossible to do
business here we can't have a clean
power coal plant that fuels those
electric cars that powers them but china
can open a new one every week good news
for the supreme court though i don't
totally trust the supreme court but the
roe v wade decision the decision that
people can individually pray which is
your first amendment
at school
the decision on the second amendment
saying you can't bar people with no
reason from a gun permit and then now
coming out and saying
the fda
and the epa and all these groups epa
particularly can't just make up laws on
their own and say that carbon dioxide is
a toxic waste so
the bi-administration officials said the
answer is censoring people
that criticize our climate policy so
it's a mafia power grab they can't
conquer us with guns because we have
guns so they're doing it economically
that's cloward and piven that's the
great reset as you were just saying i
mean that's one of the biggest i mean
it's also leading to a significant
backlash now though because i mean this
is it people people now officially
cannot find baby formula it's it's you
can't dr people are driving around to
multiple stores to find baby formula at
550 a gallon and it's like all you have
to do is have the baby identify as an
adult
there you go it's a really good it's a
really good point like i i know you're
18 months but here's a steak and some
whiskey you know grow up
well they say that men can have babies
so the three of us can get a hotel room
i'm telling you and uh you know all have
babies i'll have a baby you'll have a
baby yeah it'll be great
here's what i say alex whenever they
like that idea i love it and here's why
i think he's coming on to us i think he
is and i'm fine with it it's okay
anything to free the country okay man
look yeah we gotta fight the globalists
all right i'm not gay but olympus here
look like we're already pregnant though
okay that's fair that's fair i'm also
that's because you don't see him from
down the waist down he has the beer
belly
um
[Music]
no
he's a woman and that's your baby that's
what it is men can have babies okay
that's fair alex here's what i say
whenever people tell me you know men men
can't talk about abortion i go i
identify as a woman only when i'm
talking about abortion and i'm allowed
to do that i'm gender fluid
i am true and if you know what i noticed
too i love when they say men you're not
allowed to have an opinion about
abortion except for the guys that agree
with us with the long hair like without
they're allowed to have an opinion as
long as it's you know your body your
choice if you're wearing that shirt
you're allowed to have an opinion i'm
sure
do the universe or whatever it's called
i did it have you seen have you seen
where they have the white privilege yes
that this is why this is why i like ma
uh mike judd because idiot stuff like
he's a funny dude and a lot of people
are always going like i you know we we
need more people on the right to make
content i'm like no we just need to go
back to people just trying to be funny i
think like we lost that right
let me name drop i know mike judge quite
well
yeah yeah
let me just say i can't hang with him he
is a party animal
by the way when you're saying that alex
that's nuts come on you were you were
all kind of party animals out in that uh
in that north texas scene back yeah
i found some of your i actually found
some of your old that we were looking up
uh your old your old uh public um public
tv stuff and it was like i think you
were on like after a show where it was
like this emo girl that would like
remember that one tiffy is that the one
where he was at like the uh the
congressman's house yeah yeah exactly
man you know the stuff you used to do
you know
what you still do is amazing but people
people go like oh yeah [ __ ] posting is
this new thing i go no it's not watch
old alex jones he's been doing this
alex has been harassing elected
officials for yeah before alex was
harassing [ __ ] before it was cool